IN THE WORLD,
AND FOR ONLINE DATING WEBSITES
LIKE DATING DNA
THOSE LONG-HAIRED ANGELS
ARE A PRIZE TO BE WON.
CEO KEVIN CARMONY ADMITS
THAT ATTRACTING MORE FEMALE
USERS TO HIS SITE
IS THE KEY TO GROWTH.
- 'CAUSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
PROBABLY 65% MEN, 35% WOMEN.
- BUT TO DO THIS YOU NEED
A THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THE FEMALE BRAIN WORKS.
SO I PAID KEVIN A VISIT
AT HIS PENTHOUSE SUITE
IN IRVINE, CALIFORNIA,
TO SHARE MY EXPERTISE.
THE MAIN REASON MOST WOMEN
ARE AFRAID TO USE ONLINE DATING
IS BECAUSE THEY THINK
THE PERSON THEY MEET UP WITH
COULD POTENTIALLY BE A KILLER
AND MURDER THEM.
- UM, I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S A BIG REASON
THAT WOMEN DON'T SIGN UP
FOR DATING SITES.
WE HAVEN'T HAD WOMEN
CONTACTING US,
"HEY, I MET THIS GUY ON YOUR
SITE AND HE WAS A CREEP
AND THIS AND THAT HAPPENED."
WE HAVE ENOUGH--
- WELL, YOU MIGHT NOT HEAR
FROM THOSE WOMEN BECAUSE...
- I DON'T THINK THAT IS
THE--IT'S CERTAINLY A CONCERN.
- THE SOLUTION
IS DADDY'S WATCHING.
- OKAY.
- UP UNTIL AGE 18, MOST WOMEN
HAVE A DADDY KEEPING TABS
ON ANY MAN SHE GOES OUT WITH.
BUT ONCE SHE GETS BIGGER,
DADDY'S NO LONGER AROUND,
BUT DANGER STILL IS.
SO IF DATING DNA OFFERED
A SECURITY SERVICE
WHERE FEMALE USERS COULD REQUEST
TO HAVE SOMEONE
SECRETLY WATCH OVER
THEIR FIRST DATES,
THE WEBSITE WOULD QUICKLY BECOME
THE OBVIOUS CHOICE
FOR WOMEN
LOOKING TO DATE ONLINE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT DADDY'S WATCHING.
- EH...
SEEMS A LITTLE CONDESCENDING
TO ME TO WOMEN
THAT DADDY HAS TO TAKE CARE
OF YOU AND DADDY'S WATCHING--
- SO YOU DON'T LIKE THE NAME?
- I-I DON'T KNOW--
- NOW BEFORE YOU SAY ANYTHING,
YOU KNOW,
IT MIGHT NOT BE GOOD ON CAMERA
TO SAY ANYTHING BAD
ABOUT AN IDEA
THAT MAKES WOMEN SAFER.
- YES, BUT--
- YOU DON'T WANNA LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE NOT TRYING
TO MAKE WOMEN FEEL SAFE.
- YEAH.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT--MAY MAKE A WOMAN
FEEL MORE SECURE, CERTAINLY.
- KEVIN LOVED MY IDEA.
BUT BEFORE HE COULD OFFER IT
TO HIS USERS,
I NEEDED TO DEVELOP
OFFICIAL GUIDELINES
FOR HOW THE DADDY'S WATCHING
SYSTEM WOULD WORK.
SO I FOUND A DATING DNA USER,
KAMARIN,
WHO AGREED TO LET ME
TRY OUT THE SERVICE
ON ONE OF HER FIRST DATES.
SO YOUR DATE
WILL BE ARRIVING SOON,
AND BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING
THIS OUT FOR TODAY,
I'LL BE YOUR DADDY.
- OKAY.
- AND WE ALSO
HAVE SOME BRANDING
KINDA ELEMENTS WE'RE TRYING
TO INCORPORATE.
SO IF YOU'RE EVER IN FEAR
AT ANY TIME
DURING YOUR DATE, JUST YELL OUT,
"DADDY, DADDY, COME OVER NOW.
SAVE MY LIFE.
YOU MADE A VOW."
- SOUNDS GOOD?
- SO DO YOU WANT
TO PRACTICE THAT OR--
- WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF I JUST YELLED, "HELP"?
LIKE, WHAT'S THE SIGNIFICANCE
IN ME--
- WELL, IF I JUST HEAR, "HELP,"
YOU KNOW, THAT COULD BE ANYONE.
BUT THE DADDY RHYME,
I KNOW IT'S YOU.
- COOL.
- ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, NATE.
- NATHAN.
- YEAH, YOU CAN CALL ME NATE.
- ALL RIGHT.
[awkward chuckle]
WHATEVER.
- THANK YOU.
- EITHER WAY...
- ALL RIGHT.
- IT'S CASUAL.
WITH KAMARIN PREPPED,
I GOT INTO POSITION
OUT FRONT OF HER BUILDING.
AND KNOWING
WHAT HER DATE LOOKED LIKE,
I HAD A METHOD TO COVERTLY
VET HIM BEFORE HE PICKED HER UP.
HEY, MAN, COULD YOU DO ME
A FAVOR?
I'M JUST MOVING
OUT OF MY BUILDING.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE
TO TAKE A PHOTO OF ME
IN FRONT OF MY BUILDING?
- UM, YEAH.
- IS THAT COOL?
- YEAH.
- OH, I GUESS
I PACKED MY CAMERA.
I THOUGHT I HAD IT ON ME.
DO YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE LIKE
A KNIFE, OR ANY WEAPON,
ANYTHING SHARP
I COULD OPEN THE BOX WITH...
- I CAN DO IT WITH A KEY.
- GUN OR--
OH, KEY?
OKAY.
WHERE YOU HEADED?
OH, REALLY?
COOL, THANKS.
YEAH, WOMEN, HUH?
SOMETIMES YOU WANNA KISS 'EM,
OTHER TIMES
YOU JUST WANNA
WRING THEIR NECKS,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
YOU FEEL THAT WAY?
LIKE SOMETIMES
YOU WANNA KISS 'EM,
OTHER TIMES YOU WANNA
WRING THEIR NECKS.
YOU WOULDN'T?
BUT SOMETIMES, YOU KNOW,
WHEN A GIRL SAYS NO
SHE REALLY MEANS YES, RIGHT?
YEAH?
YOU'RE NOT A SEX OFFENDER
OR ANYTHING?
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, YEAH.
HAVE A GOOD DAY.
CODY SEEMED OKAY AT FIRST
BUT JUST TO BE SAFE,
I PRESERVED HIS FINGERPRINTS
FROM THE CAMERA
SO I COULD GIVE THEM
TO THE AUTHORITIES
IN CASE THINGS TOOK A TURN
FOR THE WORSE.
MOMENTS LATER, THEY LEFT FOR
THEIR DATE AT THE BOWLING ALLEY,
AND I WAS SURE
TO FOLLOW CLOSE BEHIND.
ONCE THEY ARRIVED,
THEY STARTED THEIR GAME
AND GOT TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
- WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
- I'M ORIGINALLY FROM ANAHEIM.
I LIVE IN WESTWOOD NOW.
- AND FROM A DISTANCE,
IT LOOKED AS THOUGH THINGS
WERE OFF TO A GOOD START.
BUT IN CASE SOMETHING
WERE TO HAPPEN,
I HAD A METHOD THAT ALLOWED ME
TO BE RIGHT NEXT TO THEM,
AND COMPLETELY INVISIBLE
AT THE SAME TIME.
DISGUISED AS A FEMALE BOWLER
IN RELIGIOUS GARB,
I WAS ABLE TO BE WITHIN EARSHOT
OF KAMARIN AND HER DATE.
READY TO SPLIT THINGS UP
IF HIS STRIKE CELEBRATIONS
GOT A LITTLE TOO TOUCHY.
FORTUNATELY,
THAT WASN'T REQUIRED.
CODY SEEMED
LIKE A GENUINELY GOOD GUY,
AND I COULD TELL KAMARIN
FELT SAFE
AS SHE REALLY BEGAN TO OPEN UP.
- IF TWO PLANES
BROUGHT DOWN THE TWO TOWERS...
- UH-HUH?
- I COULD SEE
THAT AS BEING FEASIBLE.
- OKAY.
- BUT WHAT BROUGHT DOWN
BUILDING NUMBER SEVEN?
BUILDING SEVEN.
- MY METHOD WAS WORKING
PERFECTLY,
AND AFTER CODY
RETURNED HER HOME UNHARMED,
I WENT INSIDE TO SEE
IF KAMARIN FELT AS GOOD AS I DID
ABOUT THE SERVICE.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU FELT SAFE
AND EVERYTHING?
- YEAH. FEEL PRETTY SECURE.
- YOU DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS ME,
RIGHT?
- NO.
NOT AT ALL.
- YEAH, SO...
THAT SHOWS THAT I GUESS
IT WORKED PRETTY WELL.
- YEAH.
- THE DADDY'S WATCHING SYSTEM
WAS A TOTAL SUCCESS.
BUT FOR IT TO WORK
WITH DATING DNA
I'D NEED TO BUILD A STAFF
OF TRAINED DADDIES
WHO'D BE AS TRUSTWORTHY AS I AM.
SO I PUT UP SOME FLIERS
THAT OFFERED SECURITY WORK.
AND THE NEXT DAY
I MET WITH THE ONE GUY
WHO RESPONDED TO MY AD.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO
IN THIS SCENARIO?
YOU'RE PROTECTING THE WOMAN
AND THE GUY TRIES TO KISS HER.
- I'M GONNA DROP HIM.
- WHAT DOES THAT--
- IF I DO IT HARD ENOUGH,
RIGHT HERE,
AND RIGHT IN THE GLANDS
FOR YOUR WINDPIPE,
I PUSH HARD ENOUGH TO--
LIKE THIS.
FOR ABOUT THIRT--
FOR ABOUT THREE SECONDS--FOUR,
I CAN PUT YOU OUT.
- COOL.
- OR BACK HERE, RIGHT HERE.
UNDERNEATH THE LOBE.
BUT YOU HAVE TO GO LIKE THAT
[thwack]
BACK HERE BY THE LOBE
TO GET IT.
YOU KNOW, IT PUTS YOU OUT
FOR ABOUT 30 SECONDS.
THIS ONE HERE PUTS YOU OUT
FOR ABOUT A MINUTE.
- SO YOU KNOW LOTS OF MOVES.
- I KNOW A COUPLE, YEAH.
- MARK SEEMED QUALIFIED
FOR THE JOB,
BUT I STILL NEEDED
TO SEE HIM IN ACTION.
SO I ARRANGED THE SERVICE FOR
ANOTHER DATING DNA USER
AND BROUGHT MARK WITH ME
TO HER HOME
TO SEE IF HE COULD HANDLE
HIS FIRST REAL JOB AS A DADDY.
- HOW YOU DOING, POLLY?
- GOOD, THANK YOU.
- SO MARK WILL BE YOUR DADDY.
- OKAY.
- AND HE WILL BE FOLLOWING YOU
AND WATCHING YOU
FROM A DISTANCE.
SO JUST SO YOU KNOW,
WE'VE GIVEN MARK
ALL YOUR PERSONAL INFORMATION.
YOUR ADDRESS, YOUR NAME,
PHOTOGRAPHS, YOUR SOCIAL.
SO IF YOU GO MISSING,
HE KNOWS HOW TO TRACK YOU DOWN.
- OKAY.
- ALL RIGHT, SO, YEAH.
HAVE A FUN NIGHT, AND UH, YEAH.
- THANK YOU.
[door thuds closed]
I'VE WATCHED PEOPLE BEFORE,
SO...NEVER HAD A PROBLEM.
- OKAY.
- I'M GONNA PROTECT YOU,
WATCH YOU ALL THE TIME.
MAKE SURE--I WON'T KEEP MY EYES
OFF YOU AT ALL.
I'LL PROTECT YOU,
MAKE SURE YOU GET HOME.
AND I WILL TUCK YOU IN BED.
I'M JUST GONNA TUCK YOU IN BED,
AND I'M GONE.
AND MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT I COME TUCK YOU IN.
- OKAY.
- MARK MADE POLLY FEEL SAFE,
AND THAT MEANT
I COULD NOW RETURN TO KEVIN
AND GIVE HIM EVERYTHING
HE NEEDED
TO IMPLEMENT THE DADDY'S
WATCHING SYSTEM NATIONWIDE.
IT FELT SO GOOD TO HELP
A STRUGGLING BUSINESS.
BUT I LEFT THAT DAY KNOWING
THAT I ALSO HELPED MAKE
THE WORLD A SAFER PLACE.
- HEY, I JUST--
I MOVED AWAY FROM HERE.
IF YOU DON'T MIND--
YOU GIVE ME A COUPLE SECONDS.
I JUST WANTED--TAKE A PICTURE
'CAUSE I MOVED.
- OH, UM,
I DON'T HAVE A CAMERA.
- CAMERA'S IN HERE.
- SORRY?
- OKAY.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
NO, COME HERE.
- OH, IT'S FINE.
- STAY RIGHT HERE.
NO, COME HERE.